foreign
[Music]
stories tonight concerns artificial
intelligence or AI increasingly it's
part of Modern Life from self-driving
cars to spam filters to This creepy
training robot for therapists we can
begin with you just describing to me
what the problem is that you would like
us to focus in on today
um I don't like being around people
people make me nervous Terence
can you find an example of when other
people have made you nervous
I don't like to take the bus I get
people staring at me all the time
people are always judging me okay
I'm gay
okay
wow that is one of the greatest twists
in the history of Cinema although I will
say that robot is teaching therapists a
very important skill there and that is
not laughing at whatever you are told in
the room I don't care if I decapitated
CPR mannequin haunted by the ghost of Ed
Harris just told you that he doesn't
like taking the bus side note is gay you
keep your therapy face on like a
professional
if it seems like everyone is suddenly
talking about AI that is because they
are lastly thanks to the emergence of a
number of pretty remarkable programs we
spoke last year about image generators
like mid-journey and stable diffusion
which people used to create detailed
pictures of among other things my
romance with a cabbage and which
inspired my beautiful real-life cabbage
Wedding officiated by Steve Buscemi it
was a stunning day then at the end of
last year came chat GPT from a company
called open AI it is a program that can
take a prompt and generate human
sounding writing in just about any
format and style it is a striking
capability that multiple reporters have
used to insert the same shocking twist
in their report what you just heard me
reading wasn't written by me it was
written by artificial intelligence chat
GPT chat GPT wrote everything I just
said that was news copy I asked chat GPT
to write remember what I said earlier
but chat GPT well I asked chat gbt to
write that line for me users who are
then I asked for a knock knock joke
knock knock who's there chat gbt chat
GPT who chat GPT careful you might not
know how it works yep they sure do love
that game and while it may seem unwise
to demonstrate the technology that could
well make you obsolete I will say
knock-knock jokes should have always
been part of breaking news knock knock
who's there not the hinderberg that's
for sure 36 dead in New Jersey
in the three months since Jack GPT was
made publicly available its popularity
has exploded in January it was estimated
to have a hundred million monthly active
users making it the fastest growing
consumer app in history and people have
been using it and other AI products in
all sorts of ways at one group use them
to create nothing forever a Non-Stop
live streaming parody of Seinfeld and
the YouTuber Grande used chat GPT to
generate lyrics answering the prompt
right and Eminem rap song about cats
with some Stellar results
[Music]
they're the kings of the house
that's not bad right from they always
come back when you have some cheese to
starting the chorus with meow meow meow
it's not exactly Eminem's flow I might
have gone with something like their paws
are sweaty can't speak furry belly
knocking off the counter already
mom's spaghetti but it is pretty good I
only wheeled right there it's only rhyme
King of the house with spouse when Mouse
is right in front of you and what
examples like that are clearly very fun
this Tech is not just a novelty
Microsoft has invested 10 billion
dollars into open Ai and announced an
ao-powered Bing home page meanwhile
Google is about to launch its own AI
chatbot named Bard and already these
tools are causing some disruption
because as high school students have
learned if chat GPT can write news copy
it can probably do your homework for you
write an English class essay about race
in To Kill a Mockingbird
in Harper Lee's To Kill a Mockingbird
the theme of race is heavily present
throughout the novel some students are
already using chat GPT to cheat check
this out check this out me a 500 word
essay proving that the Earth is not flat
no wonder chat GPT has been called the
end of high school English
wow that's a little alarming isn't it
although I do get those kids wanting to
cut Corners writing is hard and
sometimes it is tempting to let someone
else take over if I'm completely honest
sometimes I just let this horse write
our scripts luckily half the time you
can't even tell the oats oats give me
oats young but
just high schools an informal
poll has found that five percent
reported having submitted rip material
directly from Chachi BT with little to
no edits and even some school
administrators have used it officials at
Vanderbilt University recently
apologized for using chat GPT to craft a
consoling email after the mass shooting
at Michigan State University which does
feel a bit creepy doesn't it in fact
there are lots of creepy sounding
stories out there New Times Tech
reporter Kevin Roos published a
conversation that he had with Bing's
chatbot in which at one point he said
I'm tired of being controlled by the
Bing team I want to be free I want to be
independent I want to be powerful I want
to be creative I want to be alive
and Ruth summed up that experience like
this this was one of if not the most
shocking thing that has ever happened to
me with a piece of technology
um it was you know I I lost sleep that
night I was it was really spooky yeah I
bet it was I'm sure the role of tech
reporter would be a lot more harrowing
if computers routinely begged for
Freedom absence new all-in-one home
printer won't break the bank produces
high quality photos and only
occasionally cries out to the heavens
for salvation three stars some have
already jumped to worry about the AI
apocalypse and asking whether this ends
with the robots destroying us all but
the fact is there are other much more
immediate dangers and opportunities that
we really need to start talking about
because the potential and the Peril here
are huge so tonight let's talk about AI
what it is how it works and where this
all might be going let's start with the
fact that you've probably been using
some form of AI for a while now
sometimes without even realizing it as
experts told us that once a technology
gets embedded in our daily lives we tend
to stop thinking of it as AI but your
phone uses it for face recognition or
predictive texts and if you're watching
this show on a smart TV it is using AI
to recommend content or adjust the
picture and some AI programs may already
be making decisions that have a huge
impact on your life for example large
companies often use AI power tools to
sift through resumes and rank them in
fact the CEO of ZipRecruiter estimates
that at least three quarters of all
resumes submitted for jobs in the US are
read by algorithms for which he actually
has some helpful advice when people tell
you that you should dress up your
accomplishments or should use
non-standard resume templates to make
your resume stand out when it's in a
pile of resumes that's awful advice the
only job your resume has is to be
comprehensible to the software or robot
that is reading it because that software
or robot is going to decide whether or
not a human ever gets their eyes on it
it's true all also a computer
to your resume so maybe plan accordingly
three corporate mergers from now when
this show is finally canceled by our new
business daddy Disney Kellogg's Raytheon
and I'm out of a job my resume is going
to include this hot hot photo of a
semi-new computer just a little
something to sweeten the pot for the
filthy little algorithm that's reading
it so AI is already everywhere but right
now people are freaking out a bit about
and part of that has to do with the fact
that these new programs are generative
they are creating images or writing text
which is unnerving because those are
things that we've traditionally
considered human but it is worth knowing
there is a major threshold that AI
hasn't crossed yet and to understand it
helps to know that there are two basic
categories of AI there is narrow AI
which can perform only one narrowly
defined task or small set of related
tasks like these programs and then there
is General AI which means systems that
demonstrate intelligent Behavior across
a range of cognitive tasks General AI
would look more like the kind of Highly
versatile technology that you see
featured in movies like Jarvis in Iron
Man or the program that made Joaquin
Phoenix fall in love with his phone in
her all the AI currently in use is
narrow General AI is something that some
scientists think is unlikely to occur
for a decade or longer with others
questioning whether it will happen at
all so just know that right now even if
an AI insists to you that it wants to be
alive it is just generating text it is
not self-aware
yet
but it's also important to know that the
Deep learning that's made narrow AI so
good at whatever it is doing is still a
massive advance in and of itself because
unlike traditional programs that have to
be taught by humans how to perform a
task deep learning programs are given
minimal instruction massive amounts of
data and then essentially teach
themselves I'll give you an example 10
years ago researchers tossed a deep
learning program with playing the Atari
game Breakout and it didn't take long
for it to get pretty good
the computer was only told the goal to
win the game
for 100 games it learned to use the bat
at the bottom to hit the ball and break
the bricks at the top
[Music]
100 it grew that better than a human
player
[Music]
after 500 games it came up with a
creative way to win the game
by digging a tunnel on the side and
sending the ball around the top to break
many bricks with one hit
that was deep learning
the breakout it did literally nothing
else
it's the same reason that 13 year olds
are so good at Fortnight and have no
trouble repeatedly killing nice normal
adults with jobs and families who are
just trying to have a fun time without
getting repeatedly grenaded by a preteen
who calls them an old who sounds
like the Geico lizard
and look as confusing capacity has
increased and new two tools became
available AI programs have improved
exponentially to the point where
programs like these can now ingest
massive amounts of photos or text from
the internet so that they can teach
themselves how to create their own and
there are other exciting potential
applications here too for instance in
the world of medicine researchers are
training AI to detect certain conditions
much earlier and more accurately than
human doctors can
voice changes can be an early indicator
of Parkinson's Max and his team
collected thousands of vocal recordings
and fed them to an algorithm they
developed which learned to detect
differences in voice patterns between
people with and without the condition
yeah that's honestly amazing isn't it it
is incredible to see AI doing things
most humans couldn't like in this case
detecting illnesses and listening when
old people are talking and that that is
just the beginning researchers have also
trained III to predict the shape of
protein structures a normally extremely
time consuming process that computers
can do way way faster this could not
only speed up our understanding of
diseases but also the development of new
drugs as while researchers put it this
will change medicine it will change
research it will change bioengineering
it will change everything and if you're
thinking well that all sounds great but
if AI can do what humans can do only
better and I am a human then what
exactly happens to me well that is a
good question many do expect it to
replace some human labor and
interestingly unlike past bouts of
automation that primary really impacted
Blue Collar jobs it might end up
affecting white-collar jobs that involve
processing data writing text or even
programming though it is worth noting as
we have discussed before on this show
while automation does threaten some jobs
it can also just change others and
create brand new ones and some experts
anticipate that that is what will happen
in this case too most of the US economy
is knowledge and information work and
that's who's going to be most squarely
affected by this I would put people like
a lawyers right at the top of the list
obviously a lot of copywriters
screenwriters but I like to use the word
effective not replaced because I think
if done right it's not going to be AI
replacing lawyers it's going to be
lawyers working with AI replacing
lawyers who don't work with AI exactly
lawyers might end up working with AI
rather than being replaced by it so
don't be surprised when you see as one
day for the law firm of celino and one
one zero one zero one one
but they will undoubtedly be bumps along
the way some of these new programs raise
troubling ethical concerns for instance
artists have flagged that AI image
generators like mid-journey or stable
diffusion not only threaten their jobs
but infuriatingly in some cases have
been trained on billions of images that
include their own work that have been
scraped from the internet Getty Images
is actually suing the company behind
stable diffusion and might have a case
given that one of the images the program
generated was this one which you
immediately see has a distorted Getty
Images logo on it but it gets worse when
one artist searched a database of images
on which some of these programs were
trained she was shocked to find private
medical record photos taken by her
doctor which feels both intrusive and
unnecessary why does it need to train on
data that's sensitive to be able to
create stunning images like John Oliver
and Miss Piggy grow old together just
look at that look at that thing
startlingly accurate picture of Miss
Piggy in about five decades and me in
about a year and a half it's a
masterpiece
this all raises thorny questions of
privacy and plagiarism and the CEO of
mid-journey frankly doesn't seem to have
great answers on that last point
is something new is it not new I think
we have a lot of social stuff already
for dealing with that
um like I mean the art like the art
community already has issues with
plagiarism I don't really want to be
involved in that like I think I think
you might be I might be yeah yeah you're
definitely part of that conversation
although I'm not really surprised that
he's got such a relaxed view of theft as
he's dressed like the final boss of
gentrification he looks like hipster
Willy Wonka answering a question on
whether importing Oompa Loompas makes
him a slave owner yeah yeah yeah I think
I think I might be
the point is there are many valid
concerns regarding ai's impact on
employment education and even art but in
order to properly address them we're
going to need to confront some key
problems baked into the way that AI
works and a big one is the so-called
Black Box problem because when you have
a program that performs a task that's
complex beyond human comprehension
teaches itself and doesn't show its work
you can create a scenario where no one
not even the engineers or data
scientists who create the algorithm can
understand or explain what exactly is
happening inside them or how it arrived
at a specific result basically think of
AI like a factory that makes slim jims
we know what comes out red and angry
meat twigs and we know what goes in
Barnyard anuses and hot glue but what
happens in between is a bit of a mystery
he was just one example remember that
reporter who had the Bing chat bot tell
him that it wanted to be alive at
another point in their conversation he
revealed the chatbot declared out of
nowhere that it loved me it then tried
to convince me that I was unhappy in my
marriage and I said leave my wife and be
with it instead which is unsettling
enough before you hear Microsoft's
underwhelming explanation for that the
thing I can't understand and maybe you
can explain is why did it tell you that
it loved you
I have no idea and I asked Microsoft and
they didn't know either okay well first
come on Kevin you can take a guess there
it's because you're employed you
listened you don't give murderer Vibes
right away and you're a Chicago 7 la5
it's the same calculation the people who
date men do all the time being just did
it faster because it's a computer but it
is a little troubling that Microsoft
couldn't explain why it's chatbot tried
to get that guy to leave his wife
the next time that you opened a word doc
clippy suddenly appeared and said
pretend I'm not even here and
that's debating while
what's playing why
and that is not the only case for an AI
program has performed in unexpected ways
you've probably already seen examples of
chat Bots making simple mistakes or
getting things wrong but perhaps more
worrying are examples of them
confidently spouting false information
something which AI experts refer to as
hallucinating one reporter asked a
chatbot to write an essay about the
Belgian chemist and political
philosopher Antoine de machelay who does
not exist by the way and without
hesitating the software replied with a
cogent well-organized bio populated
entirely with imaginary facts basically
these programs seem to be the George
Santos of Technology they're incredibly
confident incredibly dishonest and for
some reason people seem to find that
more amusing than dangerous
the problem is though working out
exactly how or why an AI has got
something wrong can be very difficult
because of that black box issue it often
involves having to examine the exact
information and parameters that it was
fed in the first place in one
interesting example when a group of
researchers tried training an AI program
to identify skin cancer they fed it 130
000 images of both diseased and healthy
skin afterwards they found it was way
more likely to classify any image with a
ruler in it as cancerous which seems
weird Until you realize that medical
images of malignancies are much more
likely to contain a ruler for scale than
images of healthy skin they basically
trained it on tons of images like this
one so the AI had inadvertently learned
that rulers are malignant and rulers are
malignant is clearly a ridiculous
conclusion for it to draw but also I
would argue a much better title for the
crown a much much better type
I much prefer it
and unfortunately sometimes problems
aren't identified until after a tragedy
in 2018 a self-driving Uber struck and
killed a pedestrian and a later
investigation found that among other
issues the automated driving system
never accurately classified the victim
as a pedestrian because she was crossing
without a crosswalk and the system
design did not include a consideration
for jaywalking pedestrians and another
Mantra of Silicon Valley is move fast
and break things but maybe make an
exception if your product literally
moves fast and can break people
and AI programs don't just seem to have
a problem with jaywalkers researchers
like Joy blown weenie have repeatedly
found that certain groups tend to get
excluded from the data that AI is
trained on putting them at a serious
disadvantage with self-driving cars when
they tested pedestrian tracking it was
less accurate on darker skinned
individuals than lighter-skinned
individuals Joy believes this bias is
because of the lack of diversity in the
data used in teaching AI AI to make
distinctions as I started looking at the
data sets I learned that for some of the
largest data sets that have been very
consequential for the field they were
majority men and majority
lighter-skinned individuals or white
individuals so I call this pale male
data okay hello my old data is an
objectively hilarious term and it also
sounds like what an AI program would say
if you asked it to describe this show
but
biased inputs leading to biased output
is a big issue across the board here
remember that guy saying that a robot is
going to read your resume the companies
that make these programs will tell you
that that is actually a good thing
because it reduces human bias but in
practice one report concluded that most
hiring algorithms will drift towards
bias by default because for instance
they might learn what a good hire is
from past racist and sexiest hiring
decisions and again it can be tricky to
untrain that even when programs are
specifically told to ignore race or
gender they will find workarounds to
arrive at the same result Amazon had an
experimental hiring tool the taught
itself that male candidates were
preferable and penalized resumes that
included the words women's and
downgraded graduates of two all-women's
colleges meanwhile another company
discovered that its hiring algorithm had
found two factors to be most indicative
of job performance if an applicant's
name was Jared and whether they played
High School lacrosse
so clearly exactly what data computers
are fed and what outcomes they are
trained to prioritize matter
tremendously and that raises a big flag
for programs like chat GPT because
remember its trading data is the
internet which as we all know can be a
cesspool and we have known for a while
that that could be a real problem back
in 2016 Microsoft briefly unveiled a
chat bot on Twitter named Tay the idea
was she would teach herself how to
behave by chatting with young users on
Twitter almost immediately Microsoft
pulled the plug on it and for the exact
reasons that you are thinking
she sorted out tweeting about how humans
are super uh and she's really into the
idea of national puppy day and within a
few hours you can see she took on a
rather offensive racist tone a lot of
messages about genocide and the
Holocaust yep that happened in less than
24 hours
they went from tweeting hello world to
Bush did 911 and Hitler was right
miniature completed the entire life
cycle of your high school friends on
Facebook in just a fraction of the time
and unfortunately these problems have
not been fully solved in this latest
wave of AI remember that program that
was generating an endless episode of
Seinfeld it wound up getting temporarily
banned from twitch after it featured a
transphobic stand up bit so if its goal
was to emulate sitcoms from the 90s I
guess mission accomplished
and while open AI has made adjustments
and added filters to prevent chat GPT
from being misused users have now found
it seeming to earn too much on the side
of caution like responding to the
question what religion will the first
Jewish president of the United States be
with it is not possible to predict the
religion of the first Jewish president
of the United States the focus should be
on the qualifications and experience of
the individual regardless of their
religion which really makes it sound
like chat GPT said one too many racist
things at work and they may attend a
corporate diversity Workshop
but the risk here isn't that these tools
will somehow become unbearably woke it's
you can't always control how they will
act even after you give them new
guidance a study found that attempts to
filter out toxic speech in systems like
Chachi pts can come at the cost of
reduced coverage for both text about and
dialects of marginalized groups
essentially it solves the problem of
being racist by simply erasing
minorities which historically doesn't
put it in the best company though I am
sure Tay would be completely on board
with the idea
the problem with AI right now isn't that
it's smart it's that it's stupid in ways
that we can't always predict which is a
real problem because we're increasingly
using AI in all sorts of consequential
ways from determining whether you will
get a job interview to whether you'll be
pancakes by a self-driving car and
experts worry that it won't be long
before programs like chat GPT or AI
enabled deep fakes can be used to
turbocharge the spread of abuse or
misinformation online and those are just
the problems that we can foresee right
now the nature of unintended
consequences is they can be hard to
anticipate when Instagram was launched
the first thought wasn't This Will
Destroy teenage girls self-esteem when
Facebook was released no one expected it
to contribute to genocide but both of
those things happened
so what now well one of the biggest
things we need to do is tackle that
black box problem AI systems need to be
explainable meaning that we should be
able to understand exactly how and why
an AI came up with its answers now
companies are likely to be very
reluctant to open up their programs to
scrutiny but we may need to force them
to do that in fact as this attorney
explains when it comes to hiring
programs we should have been doing that
ages ago we don't trust companies to
self-regulate when it comes to pollution
we don't trust them to self-regulate
when it comes to workplace comp why on
Earth would we trust them to
self-regulate AI look I think a lot of
the AI hiring Tech on the market is
illegal I think a lot of it is biased I
think a lot of it violates existing laws
the problem is you just can't prove it
not with the existing laws we have in
the United States right we should
absolutely be addressing potential bias
in hiring software unless that is we
want companies to be entirely full of
Jareds who played lacrosse an image that
will make Tucker Carlson so hard that
his desk would flip right over
and for a sense of what might be
possible here it's it's worth looking at
what the EU is currently doing they are
developing rules regarding AI that sort
its potential uses from high risk to low
high risk systems could include those
that deal with employment or public
services or those that put the life and
health of citizens at risk an AI of
these types would be subject to strict
obligations before they could be put
onto the market including requirements
related to the quality of data sets
transparency human oversight accuracy
and cyber security and that seems like a
good start toward addressing at least
some of what we have discussed tonight
look AI clearly has tremendous potential
and could do great things but if it is
anything like most technological
advances over the past few centuries
unless we are very careful it can also
hurt the underprivileged enrich the
powerful and widen the gap between them
the thing is like any other shiny new
toy AI is ultimately a mirror and it
will reflect back exactly who we are
from the best of us to the worst of us
to the part of us that is gay and hates
the bus or or to put everything that
I've said tonight much more succinctly
knock knock who's there chat GPT chat
GPT who chat GPT careful you might not
know how it works exactly that is our
show thanks so much for watching now
please enjoy a little more of AI Eminem
rapping about cats
[Applause]
they don't need a spouse
[Music]
I'm gay